[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économiques du territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines et pour ce dernier numéro de
l'année 2022 nous sommes à Skywest cet
espace dédié aux activités culturelles
et aux loisirs étant pleine mutation
durant le premier semestre 2023 de
nouvelles enseignes vont faire leur
ouverture avec des activités ludiques
pour tous ces ouvertures s'inscrivent
dans la nouvelle stratégie du nouveau
propriétaire la société des grands
magasins ce propriétaire est arrivé en
2020 à travers le rachat de cet espace
et vous allez découvrir justement dans
ce numéro les nouvelles enseignes qui
vont ouvrir mais en attendant voici le
programme du 51e numéro du skyco la
deuxième promotion du programme
entrepreneuriat pour tous proposés par
le ski cube a été diplômé rencontre avec
les 11 entrepreneurs en herbe de
nouvelles enseignes à Skywest les
premières concrétisations de la
stratégie du nouveau propriétaire la
société des grands magasins découverte
dans cette édition enfin retour sur une
initiative solidaire de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines en collaboration avec les
entreprises et les associations les
Lutins de Noël on commence ce skyco avec
le programme entrepreneuriat pour tous
11 56 noises et 50 chinois ont suivi une
formation à l'entrepreneuriat pendant
trois mois au ski cube arrivé avec un
projet ils ont la possibilité
aujourd'hui de créer leur entreprise
alors en quoi consiste ce programme
regardez ce décryptage
[Musique]
pour moi c'est l'indépendance la
persévérance un défi c'est l'engagement
la volonté de réussir par soi-même je
dirais la confiance
[Musique]
entrepreneuriat pour tous c'est un
nouveau concept que nous avons lancé
l'année dernière pour permettre aux
personnes qui sont un peu plus éloignées
de l'emploi de créer leur propre
entreprise et leur bénéficient de 250
heures de formation sur trois mois qui
sont complètement gratuites et offertes
par l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines la première promotion on avait
eu 14 personnes en formation sur ces 14
personnes 8 ont créé leur entreprise
[Musique]
je suis animatrice sociale et j'ai
décidé de créer une société qui
s'appelle Atoum amine qui a pour but de
proposer de l'animation auprès de
personnes âgées et en situation de
handicap pour pouvoir rompre l'isolement
je vais développer des activités de
coaching et de formation dans le domaine
des biotechnologies puisque c'est là
d'où je viens depuis 25 ans de carrière
et par contre en terme de d'activités
spécifiques ça va être d'amener de
l'humanité dans le management je suis
esthéticienne de formation et je compte
ouvrir une un beauty bar un bar à beauté
on va proposer des prestations de beauté
au niveau de l'onglerie vernis semi
permanent pose de faux-ongles il y aura
un espace également dédié à l'épilation
et il y aura également un espace dédié
aux prestations autour du regard
[Musique]
récolter des jouets auprès des salariés
du territoire le but du bus de Noël une
initiative de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
en collaboration avec les entreprises et
les associations du territoire le
premier décembre dernier le bus de Noël
a fait sa tournée auprès des sociétés du
territoire exemple chez Asmodée
l'éditeur de jeux à donner des produits
de sa gamme de jeu de société les
détails dans cet insta écho
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez avoir des dobble vous allez
avoir également des onlocks des jeux ou
descape game en qu'on peut faire entre
amis vous allez avoir aussi également
quelques posters Pokémon qui qui vont
être distribués des gop-up plusieurs
timelines également le jeu pour nous
c'est très important c'est un peu notre
ADN de pouvoir partager des bons moments
en famille entre amis et on sait que ça
sera pas possible et là pour pas mal de
personnes et dans le besoin on bien sûr
avec grand plaisir de les aider pour
passer du bon moment de famille avec
leurs proches
[Musique]
depuis deux ans on a lancé donc la Task
Force RH qui regroupe aujourd'hui 80 à
85 entreprises ce qui représente 150
acteurs RH et nous passons avec un bus à
prêter par la RATP et nous allons
collecter des jouets comme vous le voyez
aujourd'hui le bus est rempli nous
allons les connecter pour ensuite les
distribuer à 5 associations qui sont
partenaires et j'ai donc de mi-spop
l'association Aurore balisquy le Secours
Catholique et les Restos du coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous venez de voir ces images d'archives
de Skywest inauguré en 2005 ce site de
près de 40 mm² sur 4 niveaux et dédié
aux activités culturelles et de loisirs
propriétés de ce site depuis 2020 la
société des grands magasins engagent une
phase de transformation de ce site pour
en parler nous sommes avec Eric Veillard
bonjour bonjour
alors est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
depuis l'acquisition en 2020 quel bilan
vous faites de votre activité de vos
travaux alors depuis 2020 on a réalisé
pas mal de projets alors on a déjà été
un petit peu en difficulté par rapport
aux différentes crises qui sont passées
et on a profité de ces moments un petit
peu d'inactivité contrainte pour
préparer et mettre en place notre projet
donc on a démoli tous les niveaux
inférieurs qui étaient fermés depuis de
nombreuses années donc on en a profité
pour tout raser et on a étudié tous les
différents projets pour aboutir un gros
parc de loisirs qu'on va installer et
qu'on va ouvrir sur cette fin d'année
2022 et début d'année 2023 et donc voilà
il y a des grosses enseignes qui
arrivent et on est ravis de présenter ça
sur le territoire de l'agglo et puis sur
toute l'Île-de-France sur ce centre ça
va être quelque chose d'exclusif unique
ça va être un parc de loisirs indoor
dans un centre commercial alors on va
rentrer dans les détails après on ira
d'ailleurs pas hésiter les futurs
enseignes les espaces qui sont
actuellement en travaux ou en finition
d'abord quelle est l'identité
aujourd'hui la raison d'être de la
Société des grands magasins pour qu'on
fasse connaissance un peu avec vous
alors la société des grands magasins
c'est une entité une foncière
immobilière qui qui s'est spécialisé
dans le la redynamique des
centres-villes en fait on croit en
l'hypersante en la proximité avec les
clients et les commerçants et donc les
centres commerciaux qui sont en plein
centre-ville qui sont un petit peu en
perte de vitesse
nous les rachetons nous les
restructurons et nous les
recommercialisons alors je le disais au
début on a vu les images d'archives
d'ailleurs une inauguration en 2005 ce
site a plus de plus de 15 ans maintenant
justement vous vous inscrivez dans les
sentiers battus c'est à dire c'était
initialement un site de culture et de
loisirs vous sortez pas de ses sentiers
il a eu plusieurs stratégies ce il a été
à la base un centre pour le shopping
traditionnel il y a eu
un projet de outlet de luxe qui n'a pas
abouti
l'ancien propriétaire c'est réacé sur
l'origine du centre le loisir nous
l'avons racheté et nous allons au bout
de ce projet loisirs on va réinvestir on
va innover et on va faire appel à des
nouvelles enseignes qui apporteront tout
leur savoir-faire à ce à ce pour ce
centre ce qui en mérite et du coup là je
peux déjà vous annoncer les grosses
enseignes qui arriveront ça sera du coup
speed Park qui est une ancienne loisirs
donc il y a du karting du bowling du
billard
c'est quelque chose de
d'unique dans un centre commercial avec
en particulier du karting électrique qui
passera quand vous le verrez tout à
l'heure dans dans le mail en plein
centre et en plein milieu des visiteurs
vous avez déjà une ouverture alors
l'ouverture de speed par pour le premier
trimestre 2022 et alors pour vous dire
ce serait plus sur la mi-janvier le
deuxième ancienne qui arrive et donc la
deuxième ancienne en 2020
et où l'ouverture est dans les prochains
jours ça sera happy c'est une enseigne
d'escalade on va essayer d'aller voir un
peu comment ça se passe justement ça
marche c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est tout ce qui sera l'entrée le bar
le lunch le billard le bowling et en
dessous vous aurez l'accès au karting
électrique et derrière là vous avez la
piste de carte le plus de cartes qui
traverse qui traverse le mail d'accord
et ça c'est unique en France des
kartings qui passent dans un centre
commercial en plein milieu du public ça
ne se fait pas on va aller voir
justement parce qu'il y a déjà on peut
déjà voir des choses ici vous avez 16
pistes de bowling qui seront à
disposition du public vous allez avoir
des du billard qui sera ici un bar une
espace de détente lunch pour prendre des
apéros des karaoké box donc là vous
allez pouvoir à venir avec des amis et
puis aller venir chanter vous amuser
vous restaurer boire un petit peu pour
vous amuser dans des box où vous pourrez
chanter et voilà vous amusez quoi donc
tout ce que fait c'est faire speed Park
sur tous ces projets
donc SpeedPark c'est sur 6000 m² de
loisirs donc le niveau de sur Skywest ça
sera uniquement dédié au bowling enfin
tout ce qui est divertissement et en
dessous là vous rentrez dans le dur
c'est du karting électrique donc là on
arrive au niveau 1 le plus bas du centre
commercial et là ça sera à la zone
dédiée au quartier électrique avec la
piste qui passe dans le mail là et puis
tout le cheminement de la piste qui fera
250 mètres de long comme je vous disais
tirage assez serré là-bas finalement
ouais il y aura des Chica c'est pas
c'est pas coton
alors
[Musique]
Eric Veillard dernière étape et là je
pense que dans les prochains jours il
faudra prendre son courage à deux mains
c'est ça c'est ça ouais parce que là on
est dans un espace d'escalade c'est ça
il y a
installé et qui est prêt à ouvrir dans
les prochains jours donc vous allez
pouvoir voir sur les réseaux sur enfin
sur le net déjà des réservations
possibles et voilà c'est une zone
d'escalade 100% fun de 5 ans à 90 ans
tout le monde peut en faire vous pouvez
créer vos anniversaires faire un peu
tout en famille et ce qui va bien à
l'ensemble du centre commercial et alors
on voit des murs d'escalade mais il y a
aussi
un peu des parcours style accrobranche
finalement on voit des des
échelles il y a des niveaux de
difficultés donc pour les tout-petits il
y a des petits parcours adaptés à leur
âge et puis après les plus téméraires
pourront aller jusqu'à 10 mètres 11 m de
haut parfait merci beaucoup Éric
Veillard dernier info c'est un
trampoline Park qui va ouvrir aussi
début d'année 2023 vous avez déjà l'info
ouais donc il y a un trampoline Park qui
qui arrive aussi en fait l'idée c'est à
partir du mois de janvier nous aurons
une ouverture par mois donc SpeedPark
le trampoline Park
et derrière une surprise d'autres
surprises au niveau restauration au
niveau activité voilà complètement merci
beaucoup Eric je rappelle vous êtes le
directeur de Skywest
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir cette
émission en replay sur notre site
Internet ou sur l'application mobile à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]